- Is it true that you proposed
to your wife over FaceTime?
- Yeah.
- Well, don't say it like that.
- Well, it's just that I
- Don't say it like that.
- I'm a romantic, I
want to get on one knee,
and offer the black diamond ring.
But because of what we were all going
through with the quarantine, I,
- Did you say a black diamond ring?
- She, her favorite color is black
and she liked the black diamond.
So I custom made her a black
diamond engagement ring.
- That is so cool.
- She's cool, she's very cool.
- I'm telling you everything you say,
you are meant to be a musician,
everything you like,
you seem so rockstar to me.
That's why I was like,
you had to have been in a band.
- Well, I'm glad you say that because
I do think even in film performance,
I approach it from a musical stand point.
- You literally like
bleed rock star to me.
- Oh, thank you.
That's why I'm like,
that's why I was like,
he was in a band, right?
Has to be, anyway.
I love that, a black diamond.
I mean that's so cool
- Yeah, so I did it on FaceTime
because I couldn't see her cuz
of the quarantine issues, and
- Was she in Japan?
Is that
- She was in Kyoto.
She's from Kyoto, yeah, born and raised
and yeah, I Face Timed her,
and I said, I Rico, I love you.
And I wanna spend the
rest of my life with you.
Will you marry me?
And she said, yes.
So I, it happened.
But I did it on FaceTime.
- I love that though, you couldn't wait.
I love that vibe,
- I couldn't wait.
- that you can't wait.
I don't, like I'm impatient.
Are you impatient?
- Well, I try not to be,
but the problem was like
we spent this wonderful time together,
I went to Japan.
I met her in a beautiful
restaurant in Tokyo
and I escorted her back to Atlanta.
I was filming a movie in Atlanta.
Then we went to New Orleans.
Then we had a wonderful time in New York
and then COVID hit
and then she had to go back
and I couldn't see her.
And I, you know, we had
built this beautiful momentum
and I didn't want it to stop.
So I said, let's take
it to the next level.
I'm gonna, I love you.
Please marry me.
And she said, yes.
So that's what happened,
- I love that!
- on FaceTime.
- I love that you take
life like by the horn.
That's exciting.
- Yeah. I that's the only way to do it.
- Passion, yeah.
- Yeah.